This is very tragic.
It's not only tragic to the refugees but rather
tragic to humanity,
to our understanding about who we are.
Ai Weiwei is arguably the best known contemporary
artist alive today.
Years of beatings, detention, and house arrest
by the Chinese government
only fueled his fame in the West.
Now living in exile in Germany,
the artist has shifted focus from the repressions
of his homeland
to the global refugee crisis.
My experience shared a lot of similarities.
In the year I was born my father was exiled.
As a poet he was forbidden to write for 20
years.
I grew up in a condition where I was being
completely discriminated and being mistreated.
And yeah, it is very similar to a refugee’s condition.
The artist’s debut feature film, Human Flow,
which will be released in the U.S. this week,
was shot in dozens of refugee camps in over
20 countries.
It chronicles the physical and emotional journeys
of some of the world’s 65 million refugees
as they flee their homelands.
It's going to be a big challenge to recognize
that the world is shrinking
and people from different religions, different
cultures,
are going to have to learn to live with each
other.
Coinciding with the release of the film
Weiwei is unveiling a major public art project
in New York.
Erecting hundreds of symbolic barriers around
the city.
It’s about territory.
It’s about borders.
It’s about immigration.
And of course it has something to do with
the current condition to limit people,
a travelling ban, or build the new border
to limit immigration
or people even to travel.
Government restrictions on the rights of individuals
to travel
is a major theme in Weiwei’s work and life.
My passport has been in the possession of
Chinese government for years.
By refuse to me to have my passport limit
my freedom to travel.
As artist I would have shows in world wide
institutions I cannot really attend.
So trying to reduce my voice or my possibility
for creativity.
In 2015, the Chinese government returned Weiwei’s
passport, freeing him to leave China.
Recently he’s been traveling to promote
his film
and oversee the installation of his work in
New York City—
a freedom of movement the artist wants none
of us to take for granted.